schön dank jeanette ja bei mir ist er
vorsitzender der bundestagsfraktion rolf
mützenich danke dass sie sich kurz zeit
nehmen wie bewerten sie den stand der
dinge auf jeden fall ist das ein
grandioses ergebnis viele bürgerinnen
und bürger die gewählte olaf scholz
vertraut für das was er für dieses
jahrzehnt anpacken will und die
programmatik aber auch die
geschlossenheit hat sich letztlich eben
als das erfolgsrezept auch
herausgestellt mit einem guten
kandidaten und das war unser angebot an
die bürgerinnen und bürger nicht
interpretiert das ist jetzt mal was sie
sagen und sage das was sie ergebnis
nennen ist der zuwachs in die spd
gewonnen hat denn wenn man bei licht
betrachtet wir sind gerade mal bei der
zweiten hochrechnung die das ganze hier
aus geht müssen wir eigentlich noch
nicht das wissen wir nicht aber ich
meine der balken der rote balken ist
deutlich hoch gegangen vor zwei monaten
hat uns das noch niemand zugetraut aber
wir haben gekämpft wir haben viele neue
junge kandidatinnen und kandidaten in
den wahlkreisen und für mich ist wichtig
dass ich jetzt eine noch stärkere
fraktion mit hoher kompetenz werde
anführen können und das ist ganz wichtig
was hat ihrer meinung nach den ausschlag
gegeben für diese zu wechseln ich glaube
dass wir uns sehr früh für olaf scholz
entschieden haben einen kandidaten denn
die menschen überzeugt der mit kompetenz
und letztlich eben erfahrung das
kanzleramt nicht als übungsraum begreift
sondern vom ersten tag entscheidungen
wird treffen können wir wollen ihnen
dabei unterstützen und auf der anderen
seite etwas was vor zwei jahren uns eben
niemand letztlich auch zugetraut hätte
dass die spd wieder da ist wir haben
unsere würde und unseren stolz zurück
erkämpft jetzt habe ich heute abend die
kuriose situation dass zwei
kanzlerkandidaten im grunde die
regierungsbildung beanspruchen armin
laschet hat es vor einer guten halben
stunde in seiner pressekonferenz auch
gesagt dass er eine bürgerliche
regierung anführen will wir wissen aber
im moment noch gar nicht wie es ausgeht
wie denken sie werden die prozesse heute
abend im laufe des tages aber vor allem
auch in den nächsten tagen dann sein nun
das wird ganz interessant werden wir
warten jetzt heute erstmal das ergebnis
ab sie haben in der tat recht es ist
durchaus wichtig dass jetzt eben erstmal
verlässliche zahlen auch aus dem
briefwahl ergebnissen kommen und wer am
ende dann auch die nase vorne hat das
werden wir sehen ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich die spd hat einen
historischen zuwachs geschafft und das
war für uns ganz wichtig und ich frage
mich wirklich woher herr laschet die
legitimation bekommen will bei diesem
absturz den cdu csu mit zu verantworten
haben wir damit eine regierungsbildung
schaffen will wir sind gut aufgestellt
wir haben olaf scholz aber wir haben
eben auch zwei parteivorsitzende und
eine starke fraktion jetzt ist der
wahlkampf vorbei die wählerinnen und
wähler haben abgestimmt das heißt wir
könnten jetzt mal langsam auch ein
bisschen unter diesen bedingungen auch
die wir haben ein bisschen offener auch
darüber spekulieren welche koalitionen
denn erstens die wahrscheinlichere ist
aus ihrer sicht und zweitens welche die
gewünschte re ist aus ihrer sicht ja es
ist hier nur spekuliert worden in den
letzten wochen und wir haben uns eben an
den spekulationen nicht beteiligt
sondern wir haben auch olaf scholz
gesetz wir haben auf das kanzleramt
gesetzt und das ist das entscheidende
wir werden jetzt mit den demokratischen
parteien reden wir haben die afg
selbstverständlich ausgeschlossen und
wir werden sehen wie überhaupt eine
mehrheit zustande kommen kann das können
wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch gar
nicht sagen
vielen dank heute abend wir werden das
im nächsten tagen geht extrem weiter
verfolgen müssen ich gebe zwei 12 und
zurück zu michaela kolster in unserem
wahlstudio